here's the best part you guys ready for
this and then we should definitely take
super chance while they're advocating
for ubi in America they ignore every
other country so I'll give you this
example let's say America right now
enacted ubi everyone in this country got
a two thousand dollars a month
two grand so your happens this you know
sjw type whatever is all like this is
the money I'm owed and they order a
Samsung or an Apple product off the
internet yeah and they give that sweet
sweet money to Apple then Apple takes
that money counts it smiles and then
presses the button at the Foxconn
Factory where people on the roofs are
walking off in mass committing suicide
because they're basically slaves crammed
in boxes yep yeah you can have your ubi
and the things you buy will come from
countries that basically treat people
like slaves when we gotta get the raw
materials for the products you consume
in America as a wealthy country sure we
are a wealthy nation we can spread the
wealth all around to each and every one
of you and then you need to realize the
microphones you get the computers you
get are composed of products and and
elements that are mined from the earth I
watch the documentary about dudes mining
sulfur and their teeth fall out of their
mouths and like 26 it's crazy they Jam
rags in their mouths because we don't
want to do it so these these people who
are like it's only fair that we get
money it's like well what about the
people in these countries that are like
enslaved yeah the reason your phone is
even under $1,000 is because they got it
made in another country that's dirt
cheap what they're paying nothing no the
people working out of nothing so they
can make a killer profit on you that's
to them is okay and that exposes
everything about this fake ideology you
know I shouldn't have to work in
exchange for the money and then when I
get it I don't care if other people in
you know in it the Foxconn labs are
enslaved I was talking I have a friend I
was talking about this and I said I
don't believe you genuinely want to fix
the world the way you describe it I
think what you really want to do is save
your town your friends and your family
and she was like that's not true I'm
here fighting for everybody was like
that's no it's not you've got a Samsung
computer that's made the Foxconn Lab
those people are committing suicide and
mass and she was like what they are and
I'm like you didn't even bother to read
this you don't know about it listen man
mm-hmm you tell me you want to fight for
the world
I hear you it's idealist
I get it but you've done no research on
what's going around in the world you
have done no research to source where
your tools and your wealth comes from
and you're acting like you're in this
you know marginalized position while
you're on top of the top of the world
exploiting these under these
underprivileged people around the planet
and to you that's okay yep nah man have
you ever seen the good place yeah yeah
so I mean a little bit of spoilers it's
kind of an old show but basically
everyone's going to hell no ever that
there hasn't been someone to go into
heaven for like hundreds and hundreds of
years and they're like when they find
out they like try to go to the judge and
they're like well look what's happening
you know this person buys an Apple and
that Apple was from a country and
whatever and it was exploit exploitation
the judge was like well they can do in
fact they can search that information
can't they and they they're not so
whatever let them go to hell
just like it's got a point look I get it
man that you can improve things in your
own country mm-hmm but it's funny to me
that like I'm fully accepting of all
this stuff like I get it and that's part
of what gives me my you know world view
like this thing right here what is this
thing yeah this is the thing we used to
spin the UFO it's a it's an air duster
I'm sure we'll use it in a little bit I
bet this thing is made in China of
course it is and it's pie made by some
dude who's wearing you know cargo shorts
covered in oil and dirt his bare feet
and he's assembling things like a little
handy screwdriver and he gets paid like
a dollar a day and and that and then we
get to have our cheap products maybe we
should be more conscious I think I think
you know the polls have shown most
people don't want to buy stuff from a
from Johnny what's a good thing on that
America I I've been saying like let's
bring it back to America and someone
someone argued it to me and they were
saying about well the minimum wage
products would would be more expensive
and I said good that will that'll stop
this fast I use fast fashion because
it's pretty much across the board of
everything everything is cheap we need
to bring it back to having quality
products I've had the same phone for
four years I don't plan on getting a new
phone I don't need to get a new phone
this phone is great it works for me
don't update it I'm certainly not well
actually I I could because it doesn't
include the the new contact trace and
stuff no no no what it does they don't
slow the phone down so you can't I
thought
illegal didn't think I thought apples no
they got sued for it didn't that yeah
that's the story but either way the
that's regardless it's like if we make
quality products that last a long time
they we can spend more money because
we're not replacing it every year we're
not having to replace it it just lasts
and then we can even fix it you know yep
that I don't understand how that that
doesn't come into play when people are
talking about american-made products
it's like I have a friend who made a new
clothing company it's called 16:20 I
just ordered some awesome product they
don't endorse this or anything I'm just
giving them a shout-out it's guaranteed
for life and get a pair of pants if it
if it falls apart send it to them
they'll fix them or send you a new pair
it's like that's what I'm talking about
they're a little expensive but it's
worth it because I I've been wearing the
same clothes I wear the same clothes I
don't need new clothes it's like once my
clothes fall apart I'll get new clothes
you know it's like no that's there
there's a mentality thing that needs to
change
I just it I guess one of the challenges
you can't get past evil people like they
will agree you know they will exist
prophets wait and I was thinking about
you mentioned this there there's fake
photos that go around of Trump hats okay
and then someone will hold it and
they'll flip it over and I'll say made
in China
yeah a fake really they're meant
specific hats specifically made to lie
about the president makes sense of
course Trump makes his stuff in America
do ya there's like a bees some news ally
did a tour of like the Trump hat factory
and it's like all the maggots all the
Trump hats yeah that's the smear these
people are evil they do it because they
want quick access to power anybody who
comes to you and says I should be able
to have all of your resources but not to
work for it question this person or or
to cancel the people in power that are
challenging on their way I'll tell you
one restore and then we'll jump to the
Super chats cuz I was I was down at
Occupy Wall Street and I had some people
tell me this the goal was to flip the
pyramid you know the pyramid yeah you
got the working class you got the
merchant class you got to lose resi
whatever they said we're gonna flip it
over and I said does that mean that the
you know like landlords and owners will
be on the bottom with the least amount
and that the working class will be on
top or does it mean that when you flip
the pyramid over the bricks all tumble
down and it forms a new heap in the
shape of a bro
in pyramid with at least one or two
former working-class people on top right
basically they said that's exactly it
they did not expect and this is a couple
of activists they did not expect the
pyramid to flip over and stay perfectly
like a perfect structure yeah they
expected it to flip over and then all
the bricks tumble down and then it
becomes a jagged broken heap with them
on top
what's that saying you got to break a
few eggs well it's like yeah you have a
perfect pyramid it's designed it's very
pretty and there are some things missing
it's kind of gross they want to destroy
everything that meant that they would be
the ones in power and then everyone else
falls down to the bottom again
all I can think of is your song the will
of the people have exactly just the next
person's gonna step up and get get that
power get a taste of it and want more of
it and that'll become the top of the
pyramid yeah yeah and everyone's
everyone when you this is how you get
civil war when you have these Karan's on
Facebook and undated with all this
intersectionality garbage mm-hmm they're
convinced this worldview is true and
just yeah exactly
and then they they Body Snatchers you
rule and then they you know they attack
you they get violent and they've done it
so now when you have people screeching
and reing about not wearing a mask it's
like did I get it like I have no problem
wearing a mask but this video is
ridiculous
like what made these people go insane
someone I wear a mess walk away yeah
like what what gives don't get in his
face and yell at him dude its ability to
mob mentality it's supposed to the masks
are supposed to prevent you know
close-proximity spayed or whatever
you're getting in their face you're
increasing your chance if they have
something or you have some you're
increasing the chances it's spreading
like the people they knew rushed
full-speed into the stores to grab the
toilet paper when pandemic was right and
slapping each other here's the best part
the last and last part which are super
chests is these same people saying I
can't believe how dumb these people are
they would some what someone tweeted
you're really gonna risk everyone's life
so you can go to Taco Bell I'm like I
saw that tweet I kid you not and I was
like oh no okay dude first Taco Bell
never closed all right
Taco Bell's running drive-throughs no
one's risking anything by going to Taco
Bell
second of all you didn't even read any
of the science
that's come out so far that have stead
has said the lockdown may have backfired
the lock on wasn't effective that
certain countries that didn't lock down
did better mm-hmm and now we have the
New York Times straight up saying
Democrat areas did worse than Republican
areas Republican areas were less likely
to lock down in less care to this yet
they still don't read a single thing and
they're like we're the smart ones
emotions yep my tribe is correct we've
done no research let me stop you there I
don't need to actually read any of this
research these studies or these
newspapers because I know what's best
you on the other hand refused to accept
science it's a good Karen it's like oh
my god listen Karen Poole and so I think
conservatives I've been really lucky
that they've fallen on the right side of
this more often than not you know and
it's partly due I think to the fact that
they're that conservative media is more
critical and analytical but you
certainly have a lot of people on the
right who don't want to read either
it just so happens that like everybody
was you know when it came to Russia gate
it was all tribalism you know you know
there were a lot of people who fell in
the right because Russia gate was
nonsense and it was like confusingly
like what is this weird conspiracy
garbage
yeah we're finding out that it's not
even true and even still they bring it
up right there's it's been proven like
it's been debunked
endlessly and they still use it like Oh
Russia Russia gate and it's like what
are you oh you're living in a hole right
right s JW hole okay but goin stable
well they're their resistance okay I
think there's one really funny point
someone tweeted they were like isn't it
funny that the group that called
themselves the resistance immediately
buckled down to bend over for the
government the moment they said stay in
your home some resistance you got there
right yeah man it's it's it's
particularly frustrating because to loop
it all back and tie with a nice little
bow my friend coming to me saying you
know we need to have you know government
guarantees and going full sjw and I'm
like nothing I could send you no amount
of proof and you know it is there really
are grifters I'm not gonna name these
people but I bet I've been having a tiff
with with someone and like it's it's
become apparent to me it's like dude are
you faking this hmm like you think it's
true happening there there I know some
people who are lying about everything do
you think it's just to fit in to their
son routing money money money
they accuse me of the same thing they
say Tim only has his opinions the
funniest thing to me is when they say
that I used to be like lefty and then
became right-wing I'm like bro you're
not right-wing I was at Occupy Wall
Street and in 2011 I said to them you
shouldn't be making decisions based on
race in 2011
it's 20/20 you shouldn't be making
decisions based on race your words
people your words no no no no I know but
that's the thing it's like and and in
fact in 2011 you that's what you were
saying when I worked for fusion I made I
made some points about like journalism
and it was like stuffing of dealing with
gamergate and men's rights and my
approach was we should interview you
know the activists on both you don't
both you know sides of the issue and
they were like that's white supremacy
and so then because of this because of
some video that we promoted that mocked
political correctness mm-hmm they
started pipe like behind the scenes
calling me a white supremacist and I'm
like I didn't yes funny was like white
people yeah well what white people
telling the the mixi over here
mixie and that's what's funny to me it's
like bro you guys are so racist dude I'm
not even here you know they tell me I
change and I'm like sorry dude like I've
been listening to George Carlin Joe
Rogan Dave Chappelle you know Richard
Ricky Gervais have not changed my you
know some of my opinions have changed
for sure but for the most part you know
these people have gone nuts thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you